le gouvernement martèle qu'il s'agit
d'une simple mise à jour mais exit le
méga tunnel entre québec et lévis à six
voix et deux étages la caq revoit ses
plans un tunnel bitube qui aura une
gestion dynamique des voix un projet
modifié moins cher et qui va néanmoins
continuer d'atteindre les objectifs
qu'on s'était fixé le gouvernement
propose deux petits tunnels de deux voix
chaque pour réduire les coûts de 25 % à
6 milliards 500 millions de dollars la
nouvelle mouture aura des voies
réservées aux autobus mais seulement aux
heures de pointe le ministre bonnardel a
donné peu de détails et n'a pas de
nouvelles études à présenter je
travaille là dessus la cac soutient que
126 mille voitures empruntent le pont
pierre laporte chaque jour d'ici 2036 on
prévoit qu'il y aura presque 143 milles
déplacements entre les deux rives et le
gouvernement souhaite aussi encourager
le développement des communautés plus à
l'est mon équipe pour dire à ces
familles parce que c'est la mode
aujourd'hui la densification que tu dois
vivre dans une tour le gouvernement seul
peut décider s'ils vont de l'avant ou
non sans amusement de québec aujourd'hui
je je je peux pas faire l'apologie de ce
projet de bruno marchand n'est pas
convaincu pour l'instant les impacts sur
l'environnement du tunnel inquiète le
dormeur ben on peut pas être assurée est
ce que l'étalement urbain ça signifie
que les communautés ne peuvent plus
développées de non sens le maire de
lévis lui est sans équivoque moi je
trouve c'est un excellent projet je suis
convaincu que ces projets là va aller
chercher l'acceptabilité sociale les
citoyens sont partagés c'est une bonne
chose
pense pas que c'est une bonne idée quand
je pense qu'on devra entretenir ce qu'on
a déjà correcte sahraouis et moi c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît c'est un
projet qui est nécessaire alors que le
fédéral répète que ses priorités
demeurent les projets de transport en
commun françois legault est catégorique
il réclame qu'ottawa a payé une partie
de la facture évidemment le mot ce matin
je veux pas envisager d'autre scénario
que de voir le fédéral
présent pour 40% le gouvernement legault
avait promis une première pelletée de
terre pour son projet de troisième bien
avant la fin d'un premier mandat il lui
reste un peu moins de six mois ici
pierre alexandre bolduc radio canada
québec